Hi YouTube. This is Professor Jang. Um,
today is my last day in Beijing.
Tomorrow morning I bought a flight with
my two boys for Toronto, Canada. That's
where I was uh that's where I grew up.
My parents are there. So, it's really
the first time my kids are seeing u
their grandparents and everyone's very
excited about it.
Um this morning my wife and I,
we sent our three kids to kindergarten.
Then we went to the hospital um so I
could do some blood work. Um I have high
blood pressure. I'm I turned 50 next
year. So um my wife is very anxious
about my um my health. Um and then after
the hospital, I checked the news and
Israel is is attacking um Iran. So, um I
in my previous pre previous videos have
said that this would happen, but I am
surprised by the accelerated timeline.
Um it seems we are headed towards World
War II far faster and and um far harder
than I could um ever imagine. Um so um
like everyone else
um I'm I'm just praying and um hoping
that things turn out for the best, but
also preparing for the worst. So, this
is really the first time that I've had a
chance to talk directly uh to you guys.
Um so, let me let me tell you about
myself. Um why I'm teaching this course
and what my plans are for the future of
this class. So um I was born in China in
1976 but when I was six my family and I
immigrated to Toronto, Canada and um my
family was poor. Uh but I worked really
hard. I got a full scholarship to go to
Yale University and I was really
thankful to my teachers and the
opportunity to empower myself for
education. So after I graduate from Yale
with with a um degree in English
literature, I returned to China and I've
been ever since working in education um
doing everything I can I could possibly
do in order to promote education reform
in China. And I've worked various
capacities. I've um obviously worked as
an English teacher, but I've also worked
as a principal, a curriculum director, a
teacher trainer. I've worked um in all
levels of education in China,
kindergarten, primary school, junior
high, high school, university as well.
Um
3 years ago, I got hired at this school
that I'm at now, a private school in
Beijing that helps students um go
abroad. And I first came in actually as
a curriculum director um overseeing the
uh humanities curriculum at the school,
which is what I specialize in. Um, but
the school needed teachers because of
COVID. Um, it was really hard to recruit
teachers back then. So, I I I was
teaching AP English and it was my first
touch first time teaching advanced
placement English. I really didn't know
what I was doing. So, I just thought
that we would just read a lot of books.
So, the kids and I we read Julius
Caesar, uh, Paradise Lost, uh, Virginia
Wolf, uh, Dante Divine Comedy, The
Iliad. Um, and the kids loved it and I
love teaching it. So um in the second
year I built a great books program at
the school and again it was extremely
successful. We read uh the Iliad, the
Odyssey, the Iniad, the Bible, the
Divine Comedy and the kids loved it. But
while teaching it I recognized there was
a problem and the problem was the kids
being Chinese had absolutely no
historical context to work with. So this
year I started to develop a new program
uh which which is the program that
you've experienced you've been
experiencing for the last 60 classes. Uh
my goal this year was to teach the
entirety of human history from the Ice
Age up until the American Empire uh
which is what I taught uh yesterday. And
again it's been great for uh for the
kids. uh and it's been great for me
because it's really offered me an
opportunity to think very deeply about
history. Um specifically it's given me
an opportunity to think about the
possibilities of history and over the
course of teaching this course um I've
decided that I want to create a new
intellectual movement a new sort of
history and I call it predictive history
and the idea is that uh in the future I
hope that history is able to accomplish
three major goals. Uh the first goal is
um to connect the events of the past
into a coherent story.
Second is to help us understand explain
the present. And the third goal is to be
able to predict the future. And I think
that if what we teach accomplish all
three goals, then it must be true
history. And I think if we have true
history then we humanity the world can
better organize um can better um control
our future and uh that's my ambition. Um
as you can imagine I was deeply inspired
by the works of Isaac Asimov. Um as a
young boy growing up in Toronto, Canada,
I didn't have that many friends but I
read a lot of books and uh one of my
favorite series was the foundation
series and in it Isaac Asmar proposed
the idea of psycho history uh which is
the idea that we can mathematically uh
model the present and the past so as to
predict the future and that I think is
will be my future ambition moving
forward. Um I want to build build
intellectual foundations for the
possibility of psycho history and that's
my long-term thinking. Um so about this
course so um I I initially uploaded the
classes so that my students can review
uh the lectures because these are
Chinese students and their English is
not that great. Um and um there were a
couple hundred subscribers initially and
everyone was fantastic. I'm so thankful
for these um initial subscribers because
they believed in me. They commented,
give me valuable feedback and I try to
interact with them as much as possible
this past month. Something odd happened.
Uh my channel just blew up. Uh, I went
from like 300 subscribers and at the
beginning of um May to about 20,000 um
as we speak right now and it's
constantly growing and um the feedback
has been overwhelmingly positive. So,
thank you so much for subscribing, for
liking, for commenting. Uh I try to read
every comment, but as you can imagine,
um there's just so many comments and I
would like to respond to every one of
them. But again, um there's so much
going on in my life. I have three young
kids um that I have to take care take
care of my with my wife. Um I also have
to prep for classes and because I have
three young kids, I've been sick a lot.
Um it's allergy season in China. CO's
still going strong. So um um um I'm
trying I'm I'm just trying my best right
now to um take care of my my kids. So,
my apologies if I don't respond. Um, I
will try to respond over the summer, but
again, I'm so thankful for all the
support, all the positive feedback that
I've received um recently. Um, so I
finished teaching the course yesterday.
Um, 60 classes coming the entire span of
human history. And a lot of you are
curious as to what the what the plans
are moving forward. Well, tomorrow I'm
going back to Toronto to rest,
recuperate, um, relax. Um, it's also the
summer is also a really good time for me
to reflect on what I've taught and how I
can improve the course. I'll also be
doing a lot of reading. Um, some of you
have suggested email Todd, which I will
go into deeply this summer. Um, I'll
also look at Oswwell Spangler very
carefully.
Um, some of you have commented that I'm
very weak in terms of philosophy. uh
Markx Hegel Kant um are pretty weak. I'm
pretty weak at and I I admit that. So
this summer I will try to brush up on my
philosophy. I also need to study
economics in depth as well. So Adam
Smith um and other economists because
that really right now is the weak point
in my analysis. I don't have enough
classical economics in my background to
fully um comment on what's happening
economically in in the world. So, uh
that's my plan. When I return to Beijing
in mid August, I'll be teaching a new
iteration of this course. So, rather
than 60 classes, I'll try to try to cram
everything in into 30 classes. Now, some
of you um have bravely watched all 60
classes. I guarantee you uh in this new
series, you'll be really impressed and
you'll really enjoy it. I'm gonna add
tons of new material and I'm going to
make the themes much more salient, much
much more coherent so that you can see
the um underlying structures of human
history much more clearly. Second
semester uh which starts in February
will be a lot of fun. Um second semester
I'll be teaching geopolitics. So what
I'll be doing is I'll be looking at
current events um trying to analyze why
these events are happening and making
predictions about uh what will happen.
Um so um the second semester will be a
lot of fun. Some of you are really
enjoying this channel and I'm so
grateful that that you are. And don't
worry, I mean, I love being able to uh
teach to a global audience, and I'm
gonna keep keep on doing this for as
long as um I can. Um some of you may be
curious as to what my long-term
ambitions are. Well, as I said, I have
three kids. I love teaching and I really
want to develop a psycho history uh to
its fullest possibility. So my long-term
ambition is actually to set up a my own
school uh that specializes in the
teaching of the liberal arts of the
humanities and build a foundations for
psycho history. I want the school to be
the best ever. Okay. Um I want this like
Plato's academy. I want this to be like
the Jedi temple where I'm train I'm
training like the intellectual Jedis of
the future. These will be the future
intellectuals, the future writers, the
future historians uh of humanity and I
hope that we together um when we build
this community will able to lead
humanity uh forward and that's really my
ambition. So um again thank you so much
for um watching my lectures. Um, I'm
really thankful. Um, some of your
comments um have really made a deep
impression on me and they're going to
really help me improve uh the course for
next year. So, I promise you that I will
offer a much more um lean, much more
clean uh much more enjoyable viewing
experience in September. I will also try
as best as I can to fix my hair uh
because I know that's been a concern for
um a lot of you. Okay. So, um enjoy your
summer. Um I'm going to engage in a
process of deep reflection and deep
learning, deep reading this summer so
that in September, uh in the fall, I can
deliver deliver the best quality content
I can to everyone. uh because I'm so
grateful uh to everyone for watching.
Okay, well that's it for me for me. Um
enjoy your summer and I will see you in
mid August.